okay fine i'll watch it part of what you
have to you know factor into is again
you just have to drill down on what
actually happened you have a photograph
of our client
you know in a building um why why are
you why are you admitting that
you don't have to admit the authenticity
not authorized to be there with uh
why why are you admitting that what
appears to be a podium or a lecture not
actually sure which one it's called
it's a lectern but that's what we have
obviously that presents promise for you
as a defense attorney in that you have
your client
in the building at the time of the uh
break-ins yeah
yeah i don't know the you know how to
else explain that but yeah that's that's
that would be a problem i'm not a
magician and neither is mr big me so
yeah we've got a photograph of our i
mean
he's not wrong that is a huge freaking
problem
what appears to be inside the federal
building or inside the capitol with the
government
why are you admitting that why are you
talking to the press just say
no comment no comment is always an
option you have a right to remain silent
just like your client
i'm broken